these quarantine wards in Baghdad are
part of Iraq's front line against the
covered 19 strain of coronavirus many of
the rooms and corridors are sterilized
and sealed a nurse recorded these
pictures for Al Jazeera recently Iraqis
arriving from China have been tested
here even though they weren't showing
any symptoms
medical staff say no one was carrying
the virus we trained groups from the
staff from the doctors people which was
miserable for the cleaning of the
hospital
we training groups about this about this
virus and how we can do anything
responsibility every month thousands of
religious travelers visit sheer holy
sites in Iraq including the shrine of
imam hussain in the western province of
Karbala and the shrine of imam ali in
Najaf they also spend much-needed money
in nearby hotels and restaurants many
are from neighboring Iran which has
reported infections and deaths linked to
corona virus the governor of Najaf
province says he wants visitors to stop
coming mom and hakka I am now awake in
fatahna I do not have the right to
prevent anyone from coming in but we
have asked the Health Ministry and they
have asked people not to come from Iran
or to travel there but planes from Iran
some carrying Iraqi passengers are still
landing at Naha Airport yes people are
afraid there are rumors most Iraqis are
wearing masks and even after landing
here they kept their masks on one
popular Shia holy site is the shrine of
Imam Cardin here in Baghdad one of
Iraq's most crowded cities Iraq says
that it's opening up quarantine areas at
various crossing points along its border
with Iran it's also halted flights
between Iraq and Iran for the
foreseeable future but there is another
issue Iraq and Iran do about 12 billion
dollars worth of trade every year
and a lot of that comes across the
border if the board is limited or even
closed Iraq's economy could suffer
Iraq's doctors now have to wait to see
if their defense against the virus is
strong enough Rob Mathison al Jazeera
Baghdad